Mời người dờ bao nhiêu phút, ngày 25 tháng 5 năm, năm 2019, trong cuộc chiên tình trà tại khu vực thôn
người chiến tháng 5, xá thử mong là lừng lượng trương năng phát hiện bắt dữ hoàng trọng
vinh, xinh năm 2019, trụ tại thôn đồng tồ xá thư cúc, tình khu thỏ, vì hành vi tàng
trữ trẻ phép chất bất truyến. Qua kiểm tra tổ cộng tác phát hiện trong báo thuốc là,
cất rầu trong tự quần bên phải của lời cửa, có hai gọi dạy chứa chất bột nến
mùa trắng kết quả giảm định gia định là hairin, tổng khủy lượng là không về hai
chiến tự tình phút thỏ xang để bàn xá thử mong là để sử dụng gà nhân khi đến trời nhàng
ở quen, tương nhiên cho kịp sử dụng thị đã bị lượng lượng trương năng phát hiện
mắt dữ. Cuộc việc tiếp tục cho thấy sự trụ đồng cuối liệt và kiểm soát
đặc biệt chắc chế của lượng công tyng lâu kai cho các đậu trang với tổ thậm và tên
án mặt truyến. Không chỉ có lượng tượng trên nè bàn những trường hợp tự tình ngoài mang mặt
ý đến lâu kai với mục lấy sử dụng cũng nhàng trắng bị phát hiện, dụ lưỡng.
Quá vụ việc nèo trên, lưỡng trường năng cũng cạnh báo các đậu tương nhiệng
đối tượng lên quan đe mắt lưỡi lượng, đau kai không phải để bàn để mang mặt lưỡi sử dụng
hai hòa động trải pháp lột. Hòa hình bí ví phạm, đều năm trong dịch kiểm soát và sẽ bị sử lưỡng
theo của những có pháp lột.